all right jules
jules where'd you grow up where are you
from originally uh
mercier says georgia
tell me about your family
i don't know
i'm sam says three but i had hillard and
ellen kravitz which raised me
who raised you
hillary and ellen
they were uh
friends of the family uh he was a doctor
and uh she was a teacher
they adopted you
how would you describe your childhood
um until nine good
yeah and then i got crushed
you got away cursed cursed yeah somebody
else can a black man's condemned me
a black man what contemption
what is that i belong to a black man but
i wasn't from california so i got it
i have all of them so at nine years old
what happened the whole world rejected
me
so what
i say
so you were you were taken from the
first family that adopted you um
well they changed characters even though
the profile looked the same
and you were with that family for how
long until well from
four to nine and then
i started running i went to programs and
then i started running away
yeah i talked somebody taught me and
taking my kid trying to erase me
it worked
was there a child abuse in here
no a mental
did you finish high school no um i got
pregnant
at what age
17.
i gave birth almost a uh gave birth at
17 got pregnant 16.
did you raise your
no no she uh i couldn't have her
um
she kept getting sick
i didn't do drugs yet so it wasn't
because of drugs
drugs started for you when after i lost
her yeah like i gave her welfare cause
when i got her
they switched the babies on me
and it came up the drug center system
that's how i got my first addiction
so
but it wasn't my baby it was
jillian's big ass it works in apartments
after that you did what
traveled the world and then i stopped
here and
said monica put me to hell back
so you've been homeless for how long
since i was 17 off and on
how do you know
42 and walking
waking yeah
so you you're staying you're currently
staying in santa monica
you stay
right right where you saw me right next
to the freeway
yeah i'm waiting uh with my id maybe
i'll get a bed soon
you've been living like without a tent
just on a blanket well it everybody robs
my stuff so
i can't hold on to anything
what is your drug currently
whatever i don't want to do
reading and the
fake meth crap i don't know what it is
what's the point of it i don't know
it makes them happy i guess i suspect
the meth is different than it used to be
right it turns black when you burn it
how do you support yourself now
oh i live in gr
so you get you get
a check every month
uh yeah 2 30 a month
i don't know something my father died i
got robbed i think i don't know
is that is that enough for you to
survive on for the win for the month i
make do um i get close to the the
behind salvation army they donate
clothes at night you know i'll go there
get my clothes and then i get my food
from the shelters and
drugs are not a problem people come
daily
i can get more drugs i can't anything
else in life sad but what drugs other
out here on the street so far i've seen
meth crack
cocaine and
weed
that's what i've seen
you don't see the fentanyl
yeah fentanyl i don't like that
makes me sick
so is this the lowest point of your life
right now
well when it comes to like trying to do
something different yeah i kind of gave
up yeah
but it would so you've been on the
streets for a long time
what kind of things have you been
through
i i mean i've been well as i said on the
road i was okay but i mean i've had
mountains i've been builders programs i
mean i
i like i like the road but i i
they won't let me leave this time
you've been in santa monica now how long
ten years ten years
and there's a
there's a homeless feeding so you can
get your food yeah yeah um i was staying
at a friend's house for like a week
before that a week
the whole time in santa monica i had a
year say haven and a year at 409 the
rest i've been homeless and i come in
out of city i
i always hide in the shadows nobody
noticed me until i met the motto
and all of a sudden people knew my whole
story they didn't know the one the face
went to
so you have one child
uh
i didn't live
oh really sorry i mean you kind of i
mean i you guys know about my kids
before i did but
[Music]
do you have any family that you talk to
i'm trying to
find them right now um
and while these are on i i can't
i can't do my blood and check my day and
you see if i have anything
when you say when these are on
yeah
somebody put them in
i guess when i was a kid
so
do you do you sleep at night or do you i
think every night you do
amazingly enough it's loud by the
freeway yeah
not as loud than my bridge
you stayed under the bridge as well yeah
yeah that's when my nightmare began
do you have any friends
uh yeah yeah yeah uh all over the place
usually when we part ways they disappear
they forget who i am
do you deal with emotions like
depression or yeah yeah i i uh yeah
depression
adhd
yeah
passion a lot
they won't allow me to feel the emotion
have you had jobs throughout your life
oh yeah i shot working out they let me
like what kind of jobs i was a painter
um
worked in a deli
took care of a couple elderly um
i didn't have the license or anything
uh
yeah
i'd always do the work nobody wanted to
do right
oh yeah
tree trimming
rv
walmart norman lures a boxing company
tree charming company what was your
favorite memory in your life my favorite
memory favorite time of your life
i guess the day i gave birth to my my
favorite my
my daughter
the one i remember giving birth to you
what do you worry about now
what are you afraid of uh
then i won't find my family and get off
the streets
you think there's a chance you'll be
here for the rest of your life you know
the money's only the real the fantasy
world to them i don't know why they
don't want to make it real and do what
they need to do
have all their sins for you you know
i can't come back as a child again
if you had your life to live all over
again what would you have done
differently
very well
i'm sorry people swear you will
god's option
do you have any regrets in your life
i wasn't so nice
i was so nice my life would be different
it's a pretty doggy dog on the streets
isn't it ah just for me
it causes a hits and miss
i'd like to skate go through all
[ __ ]
how do you think this life living on the
streets has changed you
that's all i know
i'm practically born out here
and everything you need to know about it
without hooking
what kind of things does a person need
to know living
this life lifestyle don't get homeless
you'll never get out
it's almost like once you get stuck here
you you never really
break i mean it's easy for them to break
your memory of your family and just
alienate you i mean that's what they
they watching america so many times i
don't know
maybe it's from saying maybe it's my
father maybe
but i mean my moon's beyond the first
record where have you stayed other than
santa monica oh all over the place uh
florida
georgia colorado montana texas
washington oregon
california arkansas oklahoma ohio
all over los angeles is probably the
easiest or warmest
it's the best climate there's also
there's resources sometimes oh yeah they
don't need nothing all these resources
you never get nowhere
do you think if you've got housing you'd
be comfortable in it or do you think
you'd oh yeah i had an apartment for a
year i didn't get thrown out i got set
up
the mexicans had sex on my back i don't
know
long story anyway she was downstairs
with paperwork to get me to sign myself
out
it's her baby i got from the hospital or
at least they switch it when i got here
have you been in love before huh have
you been in love before
i consider it love i mean
to understand man not really
no
kind of month twice three
is it hard for a woman living on the
streets here
um they always saw me as this like
little tomboy i've never seen i was
always shadow
and i didn't have problems recently
but everybody seems to know me
a girl has no idea
what's the worst thing you've gone
through
from living on the streets
i have to say it's when they invited me
in my life were told
i did 25 30 years all over again not to
do this past time
and two were inside
in prison no no no in an apartment and
409 equipment i know they portrayed me
as black for some reason in an apartment
anyways
but yeah
and jules what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
don't be good
they don't like good
all right
jules thank you so much for sharing your
story
i wish you the best of luck out there
you